well the first one I would take is the
dollar I think we need to really mount a
major effort to reset the global
exchange rates the dollar needs to other
currencies need to revalue against the
dollar so the dollar would be worth
relatively less and I'd like to be able
to do that through negotiations in the
international monetary fund and the g20
even in the World Trade Organization and
I think we should try that if that
doesn't work then of course we'll have
to think of other steps that we might
have to take but we should try to
negotiate a serious resetting of
currencies I think we should lead an
effort to create a new global financial
currency system one based on a basket of
currencies not just the dollar I am
maybe even eventually a single global
currency we had a gold standard of
course in the late 19th century and
first half the 20th century and that was
a single global currency it has is it's
it has advantages and disadvantages but
in a globalized integrated world economy
it that's a direction in which I think
we should be going beyond that I think
it's very important for the United
States to respond to these investment
incentives that are being offered by
other countries to induce the movement
of of productive facilities out of the
US and to offshore locations so I would
have a war chest or a fund that I would
call a matching fund and so every time a
country offered to make a capital grant
or a tax rebate to a global company in
the u.s. I would match it to try to keep
that production in the US
I think we should have a national
infrastructure bank and launch a kind of
an Apollo moonshot kind of project or a
Manhattan kind of project to achieve a
modern infrastructure I find it
embarrassing frankly I travel a lot
internationally and you know when I go
through foreign airports and come back
to JFK or to Washington Dulles I feel
like I'm in a third-world country just
coming here today I was talking to you
on the telephone and you know we lost
the call three times
well that doesn't happen in Egypt let
alone in Singapore or Korea and you know
we talk in the United States about
broadband fast internet the koreans
laugh at us our fast internet is what
they call snail mail so i'd like to
upgrade and make the u.s. world class an
infrastructure and that would drive a
lot of investment and technology
development that i think part of that
should be a pressure or a policy to
encourage production of that in the
united states i'd like to reduce
corporate taxes we have the highest
corporate taxes in the world except for
japan i'd like to reduce them to 15 or
20 percent i'd like to adopt a
value-added tax that has the advantage
of taxing our overconsumption it would
help to solve our fiscal deficit
problems and the value-added taxes
rebate as on exports so would make us
much more competitive in the global
import export markets i would like us to
focus on developing leading-edge
technology pretty much across the board
with industry government partnerships
and i think that it's very important for
us to dramatically revamp our
schools with national standards and with
serious testing so that we maintain
competitive education levels with the
other leading countries of the world
well I dread to think I don't want to
think that way I mean the the path that
we are on right now is one full of
sorrow and tears for Americans and not
just for Americans but for much of the
world America is the world's buyer of
last resort
America is the defender of important
global values and the world will suffer
but we will suffer as a result if we
stay on the path that we are on I like
to think about it this way we I think
about this is kind of a game of bridge
and ice ask myself each country has a
hand of cards and I ask myself you know
which hand would I like to play would I
like to play the Chinese ham or the EU
hand or the Japan hand or the US hand
and you know as I've been telling you
the u.s. hand is not as good today as it
was 10 years ago and not as good as 20
years ago but it's still not a bad hand
we still have some pretty good cards we
still have the world's leading
universities and we still have
leadership and a number of key
technologies we have the world's biggest
market we have the greatest economies of
scale potential in the US market we have
a rule of law we have a lot of good
cards but you know if you play bridge
you can have good cars and you can still
lose if you play the cards badly and
right now we're playing the currents
just about as badly as it's possible to
play them so we really desperately need
to start playing the cards better and
that's why I have adduced the press to
its plan as a guide to how to play the